in Westworld season 2 episode 6 Maeve
stands surrounded by corpses these are
the hosts who charged her last episode
she's apparently killed them with her
voice power and her swords did she
really have to do this though her voice
can control hosts why not just freeze
them like Maeve did to bernard last
season or wake them to consciousness
like Maeve offered to a carnie may have
told Bernard that she won't hurt him
because that's what humans do to hosts
but here she is slaughtering dozens of
helpless hosts which arguably makes her
no better than the humans she's
rebelling against Akane mourns the death
of Sakura and Maeve remembers her own
beloved daughter it's a comment on the
sameness of human stories and feelings
across cultures and a reflection on the
preciousness of hosts life and then may
have kills more soldiers cuz [ __ ] those
guys they're confronted by Tanika who's
challenged to a duel by Musashi Musashi
uses two swords in combat just like the
real historical Miyamoto Musashi who was
famous for using two swords Akane
asks Maeve to use her power on Tanika
but Maeve says we each deserve to choose
our fate even if that fate is death
so Musashi baits Tanaka and lets him
commit seppuku before beheading him
allowing Tanaka to choose death but does
Tanaka or Musashi or any of the Shogun
hosts really have the power to choose
even if they're off their scripts their
personalities are still programmed
they're not fully conscious and they
don't know that their world is fake how
can they truly choose death when they
don't know the nature of their lives
they go to snow lake and lay Sakura's
heart to rest in a place she felt at
peace
Maeve heads off to find her daughter
while Akane and Musashi stay behind they
choose to defend their land and stay
with Sakura spirit even if it means
their death when Delos or other hosts
come with their choice be different if
they knew that their land is a theme
park and that Sakura is a broken robot
as this inscription says everything is a
dream
this place is fake and maybe there's
beauty
in choosing the illusion like religious
faith love meaning but if Delos restores
the park these hosts could be trapped in
the same cycle of death and abuse that
may have fought to escape it seems wrong
to leave them in danger and ignorance
but maybe it had also be wrong for May
of to wake them against their will
it's similar to the real-world ethics of
visiting uncontacted peoples maybe they
have the right to choose to keep to
their traditional lifestyles but can you
choose when you don't know the outside
world hanayo joins Maeve's party as they
exit Shogun world through a grave tunnel
the way this works is that Undertaker
hosts bury dead hosts by chucking them
in these tunnels where they're taken
underground to the Mesa for repairs so
West world handles the dead without
breaking the illusion of the park
mave finally reunites with her daughter
they had lived here at this homestead
until about a year ago when William
killed them both mave broke down and was
reprogrammed as the Mariposa madam
now when she returns she finds her
daughter has a new mother
mave was replaced just like Clementine
was when she was decommissioned and this
is how West world works for all we know
this daughter had a dozen mothers
besides Maeve so how can Maeve claim her
at the start of the season Byrne Arnold
said that something's real when it's
irreplaceable Maeve has been replaced so
is her relationship with her daughter
real just when things get philosophical
ghost nation turns up and chasers maven
a daughter this has happened before may
4 members being chased and scalped back
in season 1 but this time a character
tells may've to come with him that they
are meant for the same paths Maeve
replies that his path leads to hell last
season may have learned that the ghost
nation religion involves shades figures
of West world Tex shades are described
as men sent from Hell to oversee our
world so maybe that's why may have
associates ghost nation with hell but
isn't Maeve woke now doesn't she know
that shades are just texts and hell's
just the Mesa and hosts get replaced
isn't she curious about ghost nation and
is she running away instead of using her
voice on the hosts Maeve's meant to have
maxed out intelligence maybe her
daughter and homestead have made Maeve
fall back to old patterns as a conscious
host she has to balance the programmed
feelings that give her life meaning
against the complex realities that
undermine meaning just like in real life
Lee calls dela security for help which
could save Felix Sylvester and Lee but
it's a betrayal of Maeve putting her
hosts in danger Lee at least as the
decency to look guilty after the time he
spent with Maeve he sees that hosts are
people too William spends some quality
time with his daughter Emily
aka Grace at first bill thinks she's a
host sent by Ford he tells her to
evacuate to safety but she proves her
worth by stopping a hosts ambush later
she and Bill have a heart-to-heart they
talk about going to the Raj once with
Juliet Emily's mother but Emily and Bill
have different memories of that time
some fans take this as evidence that
William is a host failing a fidelity
test but maybe he's just a bad dad who
forgets stuff about his kid Emily says
she wants to bring bill home to repair
their relationship and to save bill from
dying in the park bill agrees but in the
morning he leaves
Emily behind to continue his quest so
this is classic William he acts like a
good guy in a family man but that's just
a hired his true Westworld self Emily is
also hiding something she says she only
came to the parks were nostalgia and now
wants to leave but earlier Emily told
Stubbs that she's not looking to leave
and we saw her following this map with
the delos research symbol it looks like
Emily has a mission that she's hiding
from William she mentions being
contacted by Charlotte so maybe she's
actually working for Charlotte helping a
secured Ellis tada
and if William is a robot maybe he's the
data we don't yet know what Emily really
wants while Williams hat is black
Emily's is a murky brown gray it's not
clear whose side she's on later Williams
party is attacked by a ghost nation
which is like the sixth time in this
series of these guys have turned up
looks spooky than gone they have
captured some humans and killed some
hosts they're connected to shades and to
the maze so maybe they're awake but we
still don't know what ghost nation wants
Stubbs returns to the Mesa hub having
escaped from ghost nation he meets
Charlotte who was captured Peter
Abernathy because he has secret daughter
in his head that the Della's company
wants Charlotte has Peter physically
nailed to a chair because Westworld
never misses an opportunity for some
Jesus imagery
now that Delos is Dada's secure the
company sends an extraction team led by
Coughlin who in the space of just 50
seconds says the words goddamn ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] Dix and Jesus Coughlin
might be trying too hard and his team is
probably doomed because we don't see
Coughlin in the week ahead timeline and
his soldier Goldberg appears dead in the
week ahead Bernards had flashbacks of a
fight in the control room so it looks
like these humans are killed by
Dolores's hosts we see Teddy in
Sweetwater instead of picking up milk
like he used to he grabs a bullet
because this is the new Teddy with his
new personality he's more decisive and
violent killing a human hostage Dolores
seems concerned the new Teddy might be
hard for her to control he seems
resentful of the way Dolores changed him
maybe Teddy will rebel against the
lorises programming just like Dolores
rebelled against human programming
Dolores and her hosts used the
west-world train to blast their way into
the Mesa hub also killing the human tech
Phil which seems pretty dumb because
without Phil they can't easily resurrect
or reprogram hosts there's no going back
for new Teddy Dolores mission is to get
her host father Peter Bernard and Elsie
also head to the Mesa hub Elsie says
that the system sending out [ __ ]
quarantine notices which must refer to
these messages on Westworld sites saying
there's been a mild viral outbreak and
the parks are closed but everything's
fine earlier the site said that the
board members were still celebrating at
the
so apparently the outside world has no
idea that people are being murdered by
West world robots else he finds that the
parks being influenced by something
inside the cradle the cradle is a big
server where backups of hosts brains are
stored their minds are plugged into a
digital simulation of West world so the
cradles like matrix for robot brains to
investigate Bernard plugs himself into
the cradle and inside the simulation he
sees digital copies of Dolores teddy and
Robert Ford it turns out that the brain
bernard made a copy of earlier was
ford's and now he lives on in the cradle
a ghost in the machine
he influencing West's world he says
online that his Reach is limited but
Elsie says the cradles affected systems
all over the park through the cradle
Ford's been stopping Delos from getting
control keeping his changes like the
lethal guns
he's been affecting Williams quest and
maybe Dolores and Maeve stories earlier
this episode Dolores played the Mariposa
piano she seemed in control but now we
see Ford at the piano suggesting that
he's in charge but Ford's influence will
likely end in the wake ahead timeline
the cradle is destroyed so unless
someone puts Ford's mind back into a
body which is possible Ford might die a
final time the beginning of this episode
is even more confusing than the end
Dolores speaks with someone who seems to
be Arnold for its partner who died
thirty years ago
Arnold talks about the Escalante
massacre whether he should kill all the
hosts to try and save them from life in
the park then Dolores reveals that this
conversation is a test for fidelity that
they've repeated countless times lack
the tests on the robot clone of James
Delos in Episode four so apparently this
Arnold is also some kind of clone but
James was in a physical body this Arnold
is probably a digital simulation because
this scene has the same narrow aspect
ratio as other scenes set inside the
cradle and it does make sense to run
these fidelity tests digitally it's much
cheaper than
burning and rebuilding James's room over
and over and presumably you could run
the software fast do a hundred
iterations of Arnold in one day instead
of over decades like James but who is
making this Arnold clone in the cradle
and why and when this might be a
flashback from decades ago with Ford
trying to recreate his friend Arnold but
it seems like Dolores is running this so
maybe this is happening in the future
with Dolores trying to recreate Arnold
in a connected scene at the start of
this season digital Arnold mentions a
dream of the ocean which seems to refer
to the flooded valley of the week ahead
timeline
maybe the Bernard on the beach in the
week ahead has this digital Arnold in
his head that would explain why Bern
Arnold says he killed all the hosts he's
thinking of the Escalante Massacre
thirty years ago so there's lots we
don't know but it seems like this person
is a copy of Arnold in the cradle
probably made by Dolores sometime in the
future it's a complex mishmash of this
season's themes realness and Replace
ability love and relationships identity
and control but there is one more Big
West world mystery how does William stay
clean-shaven
when Dolores isn't around how does he
keep smelling fresh through all these
blood splattered gunfights the answer is
the Dollar Shave Club for just five
bucks you can get a starter set with a
nice razor handle shave butter cleanser
and butt wipes so bill can keep his butt
fresh when he's sweating on a horse all
day after the first box razors are just
a few bucks a month the club also does
soaps skin care hair care all home
delivered at a low price so help alt
shift X and look your best by signing up
at dollarshaveclub.com slash ASX thanks
to the patrons including Jessica Cheska
Stewart Velasco Jerry jaya retina GMO
jane and thanks to Matt and Katie for
the emails Cheers
you